you know i know what i [ __ ] can't
stand i i hate uh
um
like i
horror movies i hate because i totally
buy in and every one of them scares the
[ __ ] out of me oh really and then i also
hate in the third act
when the problem has been resolved and
then they add just one more [ __ ]
hurdle jesus [ __ ] christ
can we get out of here yeah
it's he's getting up again you just hit
him with a [ __ ] machete it's over
yeah it's like you guys are celebrating
the victory too much and there's at
least five minutes left
they're like well we know like i know
it's a great one like if i if they still
had like dvds and i had a dvd player
that could talk to my tv because i guess
that's what the problem is
is uh police squad
with uh leslie nielsen yeah and they did
a great thing like they used to make fun
of so many tropes so they were doing
this thing well you know remember you
know that that camera angle like when a
cop would be leaning down talking on the
intercom you know give me this that
and they're shooting up like that yeah
so as he's doing that they're doing the
whole [ __ ] thing like that and then
they cut to the wide and he's talking to
like a [ __ ] and the guy's like okay
boss i got any [ __ ] walks out
she's [ __ ] hilarious
the uh
yeah
no it's just you're a little person
you're supposed to how many how many by
the way i
the halloween movies
they keep doing them
there's a lot i know and and the
level of anger though
i feel like people like the first one
they like the second one then i remember
they did season of the witch and
everybody i mean that's when i was in
high school you can suck my dick mike
myers wasn't even in the [ __ ] thing
and that just buried that franchise but
then then it came well everything's
coming back that [ __ ] they rebooted
dexter
yeah didn't they catch him in the other
one no
it was i tapped out when he started when
he had like
they turned it into like a buddy movie
like he was killing people with somebody
else yeah jimmy smith that's when i was
just like all right i yeah the last
season this is like midnight run meets
henry portrait of
the last season of
dexter was
like i was like
having everyone who's worked on a show
you're like oh they just kind of phoned
it in oh no when he started hooking up
with his sister when they started having
fun i was just like what the [ __ ] i'm
out of here yeah well he was married to
her in real life i think so
yeah that doesn't mean they should be no
no well wasn't it a fake it was a fake
sister
like he was adopted
wasn't he listen i didn't stick around
to find out
i remember watching that that was like
that with my wife we both looked at each
other like what the [ __ ] and i never
watched that was kind of like there was
that whole thing of you know like
there's different kind of
topics in stand-up that become really
big
there was that was the year or two where
there was because that was the game of
thrones had the lesbian story not
lesbian but like the incest story and
you're like
oh they tried to make that maybe this is
incest yeah i think incest was you know
they remember that sitcom rom-com
remember in cescom no remember in like
the the 90s or late 90s there were
comedians that would try and work the
n-word into a joke
oh yeah like the lenny bruce credibility
they were like we're gonna try and mix
it i'm like what what are you doing no
there was a few like things that white
comics thought if they did it on stage
it made him badass i i bought into that
[ __ ] like trying to do an age joke age
isn't funny oh yeah yeah watch this yeah
bond
it bumped
it bombed well you know i think when
you're younger you know
when you first start out that's why like
i never like you know comics in like
their 20s right into like their mid-30s
you're still trying to i feel you're
trying to figure out
you know
who you are what you're going to be
doing what you're going to be talking
about so you just try
different styles so like if i see
somebody and all of a sudden out of
nowhere they're the leather jacket comic
i'm like all right i went through that
face everybody goes through that am i
the next bill hicks
i guess i'm not
no no or you
or whoever is hot right now is um
you'll see uh up-and-comer comics you're
like oh wow there's somebody doing todd
barry there's somebody doing mitch
hedberg
whoever is but like whoever is super hot
right now so like the super hot one
would be
um people doing mullany you know what i
mean stuff like that oh is that really
you know the first time i ever worked
with mullany i think the only weekend i
ever did he either opened or featured
for me it's zany's in chicago yeah that
little great little room yeah and i
don't think i've ever seen somebody as
big a no-brainer that that guy's gonna
be huge yeah he was i swear to god i i
feel like he was as good as he is now
then he went on stage and i was watching
him i was like this guy sounds like a
broadcaster like he's been on
tv he already sounded like he had been
on tv for like 20 years right um i'd
never seen anything like that and like
you know there's been people where
you know they'll book something i was
like holy [ __ ] you know so-and-so got
that that's amazing him i wasn't
surprised or anything i was like oh yeah
totally yeah that makes sense my big
surprise was uh
him
i thought like uh he was going to get
weekend update
i was like oh my god he'd be a [ __ ]
monster on that
on snow
yeah i thought that i thought that that
was the next move in that whole thing
but i think i think everything worked
out for both shows both people yeah yeah
so we're talking entertainment here with
jim gaffigan we're talking movies
it's like i we got to see the two shot
of seeing these two
like it looks like a joke
how white we are no it does yeah nobody
nobody would
look this way people didn't notice as
comedians they'd see that atc and they'd
be all right aryan
[ __ ] time capsule something
it's like
this is like
aryan time capsule we're going to take
you back america was great all right
we're talking minnesota high school
hockey
oh man um so
you're here to promote something i know
you i know you just didn't come out here
and to shoot the [ __ ] with me i am it's
flattered
no i appreciate you letting me come on
it was a tough decision yeah well you
know i'm uh doing a special on netflix
and uh i'm it's cool did you go home to
mommy i went home
i begged ted to take me back
and he was like who are you
no i uh you were 93 specials ago and i
was like yeah i would you know and so uh
we'll see what happens you know what i
mean i think it'll be all right you know
are you touring in 2022
i had a bunch of shows rescheduled
that um
well so it looks like january i'm off i
was supposed to do some shows in the
middle east but
i don't know with the latest thing if
everything's going to shut down over
there all right um international
travel wise but are you going out
yeah because i realize that people are
just going to do whatever they want to
do yeah
so i mean at some point i have bills
like anybody else so i'm just going to
do it and i'm going to do it how i want
to do it and people you know
don't like that you got to you know be
vaxxed or whatever i totally get it
there's comics doing shows that you
don't have to be they'll go see them
i think it'll all work out and i think
eventually doctors will figure out
how to beat this thing like they do
everything yeah and you know and that
whole [ __ ] false thing what's the
last thing they [ __ ] kill hpv they
just [ __ ] knock that out yeah they
can grow an ear in a petri dish like i
don't think you're really giving these
guys the [ __ ] credit
they deserve and you know we've always
done you know like you perform at at
some casinos and they won't let people
in that are under the age of 18 or 21
you're like
making people shoot [ __ ] into their body
i understand if you're [ __ ] paranoid
and stuff like that i mean
pharmaceutical companies also did come
up with synthetic heroin and killed a
bunch of americans and nothing happened
to him so i can i can understand on some
level that like you know people you know
i don't know i just think the the thing
about me with this thing is that it
because it affects everybody they want
to kill everybody
then they'd have to dig their own
ditches right
yeah i don't know i just said [ __ ] it
dude i use those self-checkout things
now i used to say [ __ ] this i'm not
working i just don't give a [ __ ] anymore
because i gave a [ __ ] and giving a [ __ ]
is exhausting because no one else comes
along and you're just standing out there
at the front of the titanic taking that
[ __ ] iceberg in the face you know i
put in my time i gave a [ __ ]
i passed the [ __ ] you know i pass it
on to some somebody else can [ __ ]
fight that fight i'm done with it yeah i
just want to sit on my back porch and
stare at the [ __ ] trees i really do
yeah for about like a
good three months i think it would do
wonders for me
it is amazing how the lockdown
we rented a place in westchester and
it's
how quickly i was like i just like
gardening like it just was it didn't
take long for me to be like i like i
like
putting my hand in mud yeah i i didn't
think about
uh
stand up
the whole lockdown happened in march i
didn't think about it
at all in april and may and as far as i
was kind of like oh god i kind of need a
break man i've kind of oh he's going for
30 straight years
and then by june
i had this really scary thing where like
i wasn't even thinking about it yeah and
i was like oh my god this is how people
stop doing stand-up it's that easy
i used to think it was going to be like
kicking and screaming it is as easy as
just not doing it for three months
and then you just [ __ ] move on
to something else because i can tell you
dude i could literally eat drink and
smoke myself to death
with enough time off i could literally
do it if i didn't have kids and all that
type of [ __ ]
i could there's a 600 pound person in me
i would be a [ __ ] house
and i would be like i mean it'd be a
hell of a way to go out there's
something to be said about that though
by the way but enjoying the way out
just dying it's 58 and every slice you
want to have slice of pizza yes i do
yeah and just [ __ ] you want a cupcake
i'd love one you know got all this salt
in me why the [ __ ] not
have you tried this bourbon no i haven't
i would i would love some would you like
another glass i would yeah do you smoke
cigarettes just not i do
not just editing at all not what i mean
at all watching me tv all of these guys
would [ __ ] drop at 58.60 yeah and i
remember hearing like uh jackie gleason
was like that yeah like his doctor you
got to take the weight up you got to
quit smoking he was like look doc i'm
going to do what i want to do i'm going
to enjoy life in the day i [ __ ] drops
the day i drop
and
i mean you know this it's your i look at
it this way it's your life it's also
your depth so if that's how you want to
[ __ ] do it
then you know
i you know go ahead and do it
same thing that's how i look at this
[ __ ] now i mean if you want to [ __ ]
not get vaccinated you want to risk
getting this [ __ ] i don't want to get it
yeah i don't want to get the [ __ ] and
like in the oh you don't know the
long-term
side effects of the vaccine you know
somebody that got it twice
and it's no [ __ ] joke it's not i
don't know who you're talking about i
know a guy who got it twice and then
when i saw him he was still not wearing
a mask and i was just like
i got the 80 bodies i go but dude
there's a new variant out there it's
just like no if it's the same guy i'm
talking about he was
i you know like i was like i hope you
feel better and he goes it is no like it
is just a text he's like it is no joke
he goes this is like so
and this is round two so i think it's i
might be thinking my heart doctor today
was talking to me about going on rounds
with people on ventilators just going
like you knew they were going to die
like they would invert them instead of
getting bed sores on their ass they were
getting them on their face it was
[ __ ] horrific
and like jesus christ he goes yeah
because because he goes you get the
booster you gotta go uh i'm gonna
i'm i'm this far in
yeah no i think i i do have to wait till
six months
or i don't know i don't know
i just
cut to a week from now me on a veteran
you don't have to work
i know and it's just like
yeah
i know people get faxed and then they
still [ __ ] get it so i get vacs and i
just still wear the [ __ ] uh mask i
just that's what i do i kind of like
wearing the mask though i you know i
think it's funny how like i i was on a
bus door and i swear i was the only one
with a mask and people would look at me
like i was wearing a dress they're like
what are you doing with the mask i'm
like there's a pandemic it doesn't
bother me at all if i'm the only one
wearing a mask i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't i actually enjoy it
i enjoy it and i just know that you know
i've gone to like [ __ ] nfl football i
just tested negative again i go into nfl
football games i just [ __ ] wear a
mess yeah were you in green bay when
yeah like i was there the night before
yeah
i was in milwaukee and then i i drove up
to go to the uh the seahawks uh packers
game oh yeah great game it snowed i was
in the lower bowl like the original
place that's where i wanted to sit you
know where those people froze their
asses off during the ice bowl cowboys
first packers way back in the day who
was it was it bart star snuck over or
was it a
paul warning i can't remember
and so you'll go uh you love
do you love you'll go to how many games
a year
i don't go the way as much as i used to
go because uh and who i i i have
something to hope to now
you like
did you go with your opener or whoever
happened to open with you yeah i went
with uh nate craig and uh joe bartnick
okay club soda kenny okay we had a and
then i had all my uh my buddies from
high school
were out there there you go
yeah so we had a crew and we just went
out and just were [ __ ]
just laughing our asses off had a great
time and then we all were just sitting
there like dude we're at lambeau field
man this is amazing yeah it was amazing
and uh
you know milwaukee's one of my favorite
cities yeah it's amazing like i could i
could live there like if i was um
if i was more i don't know
i don't know what established i don't
know how you put it like i never quite
feel like you know those people why
milwaukee because i spend so much time
in milwaukee i love it but like because
it's chicago without all the people you
still could buy something on lake
michigan and be living on a lake i mean
dude living on a like people swim in the
ocean or out of their [ __ ] minds you
got to go into a lake
right you sound like that's something
that someone from wisconsin would say to
you have to be on a lake because there's
also other lakes oh minnesota is another
like but that's a little too landlocked
but if you get up towards lake superior
man it's just like there's people it's
like they live on the moon up there i
did what was it uh
duluth yeah i did that up there uh
granted like 20 years ago and it's just
like
i mean you're on your own out there like
guns make sense when you're out there
because they say who the [ __ ] are you
going to call
yeah it's going to take them 20 minutes
to get out of your [ __ ] driveway your
driveway's like a quarter mile long
everybody's going to be chopped up you
definitely need an suv too yeah you need
all of that [ __ ] you need an axe you
need those old farming tools all of that
[ __ ]
one of those thrashers whatever the [ __ ]
you call those things
sickle
sickle how old are you when you got your
first sickle isn't that sort of a rite
of passages yeah you get a you get
you're sick
aryan farm boys get bar mitzvahed you
get your first set
at your first clan meeting they gave you
a sickle
no um
no i you know i
did some
i mean there were popsicles shaped like
sickles no my um
uh you know i grew up around but i grew
up in kind of a rust belt area where
there was farmland it was like where the
rust belt met the farmland so there was
how white was it were you allowed to eat
chocolate ice cream and we were not
allowed to eat chocolate it just had to
be no but like the northwest northwest
indiana is
not as white as the rest of indiana
so northwest indiana is like so did you
have like a breakdance crew like it was
something like that going on no i didn't
okay sorry um um but like you know like
yeah gary's african-american but like it
was very segregated like where you grew
up it was very segregated you don't have
to throw massachusetts you know it was
very segregated you know like where you
grew up and um
there's a lot of ignorance like in your
own family but uh but like you know
there was a lot of mexican americans
there's a lot of uh there was it was a
mix because of the steel mills
but like then all the steel mill was
shut down so there was a lot of anger
similar to where you grew up
you know
that's a funny bit
where you you own up to your your
state's uh uh mistakes while you should
you know like
you know because i here's all right
all right personal style can define you
as a person and help you express
yourself
and the end of the year is a great time
to take a look at your closet and decide
what's working and what's not indochino
can get your closet where you want it to
be before the new year starts or you can
gift a wardrobe upgrade to someone you
care about with an indochino gift card
offers completely custom fitted suits
shirts casual wear
and more at surprisingly affordable
prices get a wardrobe personalized to
your style and taste without spending a
fortune every piece is made to your
exact measurements and you can customize
every detail choose everything about
your suit including the fabric lapel
monogram and statement linings
you can create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly give yourself a
custom closet revamp with indo cheeto
or the gift a great style with an
indochino gift card get 50 off any
purchase of 3.99
or more by using promo code burr b-u-r-r
at
indochino.com that's 50 off a purchase
of 3.99
or more at ind wait i n d o c h i n o
dot com promo code burr
i n d o
c h i n o dot com
promo code bird p u r r
it's you know [ __ ] i gotta get out of
here but i wanna talk about this because
i also have this theory you know i have
this theory that like
you know they always talk about like
musicians want to be comedians and all
this stuff but like i think that all
comedians
have
identity
crisis or have an identity crisis what
is an identity crisis so well an
identity or
where they adopt a different identity
than who they are so like i remember i
used to give chappelle
chappelle a towel [ __ ]
like i'm like
you know like you're from great neck
you're you're not like from like the
lower east side in the 1960s
you're like a nice jewish boy from long
island and the thing is is there's no
one more authentic than dave patel
that's don't misinterpret that but there
is something about
this you know like i'm an upper middle
class guy but because
i'm indiana because i'm so white bread
looking i'm much more midwestern
than anything do you know what i mean
it's like
there's so like if you go around that's
the difference that's different that's
somebody looking at you and then judging
you saying you're that
yeah yeah
yeah but you know like
oh dude i remember one time this comic
got mad at me
she got mad at me why she found out my
dad was like a dentist yeah she goes oh
so your whole ex [ __ ] like cause she
looked at me like i said she watched
good hill good uh good will hunting or
something like that yeah yeah and it's
just like
first of all i never [ __ ] said you
just looked at me and thought that was
that and then and then also then her
idea
of like she was still way off
well you know still way off because then
she thought oh you're [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] trust fund kid it's like no i
paid for my college yeah i tried i did
you know i [ __ ] had a job from third
grade on
you know like i'm not getting into my
whole family [ __ ] history but it was
just like i mean some things could have
been easier but you know you got to
write make the right [ __ ] moves and
if you don't well and i also like i try
and you know this is just like another
kernel of and some of it is if you you
you should do that finding your roots
thing with lewis gates it's amazing dr
lewis gates it is unbelievable you
should do it i always feel fine the
white people are boring yeah well of
course it is comparison oh my dad was a
baker wow no something
amazing
my great grandfather and then i saw the
one with uh
uh pharrell on it
and they were like on this next page
we're gonna show you the white man that
owned your ancestors dude and he had to
walk away
and then it was funny though
intercutting with this white guy who was
just going like all right yeah then they
uh this uh she you gotta watch really
into making flags she's gonna watch it's
over because
you could just tell me what happens you
could save me well it's about it's about
it's about how
um the understanding of the civil war uh
is has shaped everyone so like people
you know small african-american
communities in mississippi don't learn
about it
and
people in the northeast hear a different
version of it and then like
white uh people from the suburbs of
atlanta hear a different thing and
nobody hears
you know you know is it constructive to
say
the flat out truth about every detail or
are we harping on it or is it
constructive it becomes it becomes
perspective though well i think it's
necessary
no i'm saying it's saying it's like if
we're watching the game and we see a
call and it's on your team i'm like good
call you're like bad call so like how do
you find out who's telling the truth
what that level of prejudice involved
yeah but i think that there is like the
the revisionist
history of
portraying the civil war as like
a battle of states rights is dishonest
when it was about slavery i mean look
there's two dakotas because
the south wanted to have
a certain number of slave states that's
the only reason why there's two dakotas
this wasn't in the documentary is that
they were like then they're both going
to be then we're having these two states
it's like it's not like people looked at
the dakota territories and said oh we
need two we need bob to have his own
state and sam to have his own state it
was all politics and it was
you know it was this
it's a complex
ugly thing that we're still dealing with
no no no that is that's fascinating yeah
that is yeah do you know that building
in new york do you know why that's
called the dakota no
because when they built it there was
literally nothing between it and where
everybody was settled down around wall
street so there was a joke that you were
going they used to call that part of new
york the dakotas oh my god they just
dated the dakota yeah that's what i
heard oh wow i don't know if that's true
that's crazy you know
all right if you just said oh wow it's
interesting i would have gone with it
and then you're like is that true i've
been like oh [ __ ] i heard that a long
time ago no i've heard a lot of stuff
you know you know bowery
uh
supposedly
hobo
is short for
the people that live around houston and
bowery
ho beau
all right
isn't that interesting
i thought you're gonna say where the
word hobo came from that is where the
word hobo came from houston and bowery
oh because the bowery has always been
kind of
a [ __ ]
yeah i got one for me do you know uh
right where the flatiron building is
there's that park
and you look there's like those three
buildings giant buildings and one of
them looks like the top was literally
cut off yeah that building was supposed
to be bigger than the entire state
building
uh but then the depression hit and they
ran out of money so they said [ __ ] it
and they just put a roof on it
oh wow
triangle shirt waste fire
probably that's brutal that's a brutal
one that's really brutal
yeah have you been to the tenement
museum
in new york you should check do you get
tuberculosis on the way through no it is
no joke it's you know it's brutal if you
lived in new york you're like this is
actually an apartment i lived in in the
90s but i did i lived in a [ __ ]
railroad apartment like yeah and um i
mean dude like you could literally drop
your wallet between the [ __ ]
floorboards in some areas
yeah i used to heat my apartment by
turning on the water there was no tub
when i moved into my apartment how about
the tub in the kitchen yeah that's the
tub and they had taken it out
so i had to put one back in
i had to put a tub in and then you know
the thing
for shower do you know how to do that a
shower yeah i know in a shower no do you
know how to put a tub in did you put it
in why not no i didn't do it i was gonna
say it was amazing see i was buying into
the midwest guy no no i'm not handing it
i guess that makes me
half a man
but that's all right
there's somebody to do it there is
there is somebody there's somebody but
in the great apocalypse you're going to
be ready i'm not going to be ready i
don't know how to fix [ __ ] you don't i
thought you were a handy guy i can't put
in a [ __ ] tub
i mean if you give me some youtube
videos i can figure a lot of [ __ ] out if
there's video of somebody showing me how
to do it yeah
what i can do is i can fly you to safety
in a helicopter that's pretty amazing
yeah i mean i can drop you off i don't
know how to start a fire once we get
there
do you
how often do you helicopter
to shows
um
never it's stressful it's stressful
because and you do you not helicopter at
night or people's days they're saying
helicopter that's do you go
helicoptering
[Laughter]
do you guys have a copter summer in
france
um do you helicopter uh it's it's i
don't like flying at night
yeah um there's just if you had an
engine failure and you're over like
and there's no street lights or anything
down there you don't know if that's flat
land water trees you're just there's
just too much [ __ ]
um so i fly i'll fly at night if i'm
with if i have a co-pilot i'll do that
and i've done that i've flown to gigs
you know to vegas and uh some down san
diego i've flown up to uh
san francisco
i mean that was a blast did you
helicopter right there i helicoptered
there yeah rented a helicopter and then
uh we flew around alcatraz
san francisco uh golden gate bridge and
came back it was [ __ ] amazing that
was amazing but like to just like you
know they have like tours that do that
too but like you but you flying yeah but
i'm flying it yeah and so what is
the helicopter
[Laughter]
that was one of those to be like
saying to tom brady you know you know
you could just sit and watch somebody
play football
well rather than having the rush away
when i fly a helicopter i'm like tom
brady of air aviation i am
i am
that is some tom brady [ __ ] to get in a
[ __ ] helicopter fly around [ __ ]
alcatraz and then golden glade pitch is
[ __ ] some tom brady [ __ ] if you know
how to do that it is it's
the wind current and all that
because of the wind current when i don't
helicoptering
when you i don't know
exactly
no you're not you're being a [ __ ]
[Music]
you're being a [ __ ] and i'm taking the
bait so me i know how to get out of here
like eating deep dish pizza um no but
like you're the tom brady of throwing
your opener under the bus
you're like peyton manning
protection issues how is how is how is
that uh
how is that throwing someone oh you have
a great metabolism that's like throwing
someone out of the box not what you said
what i say huh you go [ __ ] back and
watch it because you're just gonna
disagree with me like oh that [ __ ]
guy can [ __ ] do anything he can
that's what you i think that's a
compliment
but all right so all right you're
helicoptering
nothing to do with todd you were
justifying the shape that you're in
that's what you were doing
there you go make that noise you
literally moved four inches
it sounds like you were picking up a
[ __ ] home safe
you know when i'm dead in a week you're
going to feel bad that you're mean to me
i won't
yeah you will i won't i know i'm uns
underneath that heart it's scarier
i'll send the whitest lilies i can find
to your wake
um all right i gotta get out of here i
gotta go and
do something yeah call todd glass and
make him feel bad about himself
unbelievable i mean one of the honestly
one of the most lovable guys i've ever
met in my life
it's impossible i thought before this
podcast it was impossible to hate todd
todd glass but you really found an angle
i love you you know i love this
this good old-fashioned there's there's
some guilt trip coming at me i didn't
know your family you were raised
catholic huh it's i'm feeling some of
that guilt some of that catholic
that was all [ __ ] you just pulled
that out of your ass
what does catholic guilt have to do with
the fact that you trash taught glass
gelled killed killed
killed so your
great-grandfather
killed alexander hamilton out of
curiosity how would i have any guilt
about what you said about todd bled
who killed him what how would i have any
guilt about what you said about todd
glass like how are you applying that no
i'm applying you trying to give me guilt
about this todd glass thing
that's how we assert power a lot of
people don't even realize that i am
bill's therapist and you know you might
as well just come out with it and tell
people that i'm your therapist that's
why i'm still so [ __ ] up
because he's never he's not really board
certified i'm not gonna fix you bill
you're gonna have to fix this yourself
and saying that for [ __ ] 20. now i
believe our time is up
and i i wanted to talk to you about this
rate what you're doing is putting
yourself in a position of power on my
podcast you think so which is really
is that really it just shows me how
small that you are as a person is that
why you eat so much to try to appear
bigger yeah now you feel like you're
after you were being generous to this
childhood friend of yours the early year
of comedy did you find yourself pushing
him away at the end did you find that i
don't know what you're talking about a
little bit a little bit oh you're
talking about you oh is this still about
you this is when i know when you get a
new therapist when you're weaving
yourself into the narrative of my life
yeah so how often do you go once a week
you don't care i do care
i should go back to therapy dude you you
could commit a murder
there's a lot of anger right there
really is who has been i me or you first
of all it what really counts is who's
scarier
dude there's no way i'd ever let you get
those farm hands on me
farm hands yeah you guys can literally
[ __ ] change a tire a beautiful
eyeliner you could change a tire with
like a crescent wrench just [ __ ] come
up and just
just [ __ ] turn it like that i gotta
get like that i got to get that piece of
pipe give me a bun here
i want to play i want to play a murderer
you used to play chicken
in your in your souped up cars you know
in the high school on the back road um
no that's something
that's called american graffiti
that's the be that's in greece weren't
you in that i was i was in that
all right we i we should have another uh
session where we talk about
how we love acting because i think we
both love acting yeah we do it would
have been nice if you found common
ground earlier in this episode instead
of a two now you're going after my
religion you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] are
you protestant
i'll [ __ ] bury you in that [ __ ]
behind that sign if i find out you're
protestant
bill we don't get along
i think are you stopping with your
[ __ ] acting like you're not an angry
person with your little eye
you know what i think we're gonna find
out
i'm not saying do you know you and mario
batali have the exact same hands
what are you talking about i used to
love watching mari molto mario when he
he would make the pasta with the well
method i got to know his hands he's
those [ __ ] sausage fingers
are you attacking my hands i'm a hand
model
no like when we do when they do genetic
research they're gonna find out that
like
your ancestors
would be mean to catholics
and then the only way they escaped
uh
like
you know like your ancestors did january
6th that's what we're going to find out
oh my my third cousins aaron burr
shot
then you know um
those people on january 6 were heroes
they were you know look
they're not coming to my shows
i'll tell you this that guy with the
buffalo head yeah as much as everybody
made fun of him he was about 15 minutes
away from being a face on our money for
the next 200 years like
how [ __ ] close they came
they just had no plan
they got in there they did it
people were not
ready can i can i point something that
was like i don't know if i brought this
up our [ __ ] nation's capital got
taken over by a tailgate
that's what it looked like it looked
like a bunch of people tailgating
decided to rush a governmental building
and no one was ready for it it is you
know what's so funny is the uh during
the whole trump administration where
they were like
talking about like you know hillary's
going to jail
next week hillary's going to go to jail
they're going to put and and everyone
was like yeah that's ridiculous and then
uh all the other people were like once
trump's out of
uh
office he's going to jail all the trump
people are going to jail and all the
people on the right are like yeah right
and we're both idiots because it's like
there's no consequences like i don't
think anything's going to happen except
for like i just like those people when
they they wouldn't let them on the
planes are like they're calling me a
terrorist it's just like are you aware
of what you just did
yeah yeah
yeah this is funny we went in there and
we wanted to kill nancy pelosi and they
were mad
that we were gonna do that they were mad
that
yeah that's like when i used to booze
and drive a guy pulled over they're
saying i'm a drunk driver
buddy you blew a [ __ ] one
i have pale skin and it's not fair
but having said that i don't judge the
right for that any more than i judge the
left when you see lunatic left it's just
the loonies
as what the
news pays attention to because the
audiences are so splintered because
there are a million things to watch out
there that they actually have to give
these people screen times because
everybody slows down to watch a train
wreck i think 85 percent of people are
in the middle hoping the people on the
extreme right and left are going to
[ __ ] settle down
that's what i think
i don't think so you didn't like that
because that sounded smart uh i i think
that there's uh i think that uh
comparing
you know trump stuff to
um
biden's a false comparison
i think it's a completely i don't care
if i don't care if biden
biden's corpse i can't tell if you're
doing a [ __ ] i'm not kidding i i would
rather have biden i didn't say anything
about [ __ ] that [ __ ]
war monger with dementia i was talking
about extreme
left people yeah but what i oh extreme
yeah no but i'm just saying that like
that's what i'm talking about people
want to end your career cause you use
the wrong [ __ ] pronoun because a new
pronoun came out three days ago those
[ __ ] lunatics well that i just think
that like yeah that but like i mean i
also believe that
oh jesus we brought up politics now i
want to start arguing all right no no i
think that like zarya
it's mine it's my friend nicaragua these
titties are nice um all right i gotta go
i gotta go i wish i didn't have to go we
could do like a few like those are like
uh instead of nicorette is that like
filled with like sausage grease
off of bangers and mash i wish it was i
wish it was all right
all right thank you i had a [ __ ]
blast talking to you this was great this
was great yeah i could literally do like
another five hours with you we should we
should break a record we should start
[ __ ] on each other we should do like
a twi what's the longest one we'll do 12
hours white on white crime
white
two like the it'll be event an event two
straight white guys talking
explaining things all right well this uh
jim gaffigan your special comes out on
netflix on what day december 21st
december 21st wow look at you trying to
steal jesus's birthday from him right
yeah who do you think you are i don't
know jesus i'm just a humble man
humble man you are you're an every man
i'm an every man i'm just down to earth
you're that one you're serious roebuck
you know i'm down to earth
bride and lawnmower you know just down
to earth that's what you are a regular
guy
he he's he's gonna cut all this off this
is what i love about you i always
thought you were so relatable
you think i'm relatable yeah i don't
think there's anything special about you
you just come off so common to me
did you find yourself pushing jim away
at the end i did i was pushing him away
at the end of the podcast and why was
that because i'm afraid he was going to
get too close
and that i would appear weak by being
friends with a guy who had emotions
uh
i think you're first of all you're
putting yourself up on a pedestal like
you're not [ __ ] you're just projecting
i'm like i'm like the time you're
helicoptering you're you're like the
most walled off
person i said that was some tom brady
[ __ ] i didn't say
no no no hello kettle pod pot cuddle god
could you not could you at least come up
with something
i'm the most walled off there's all
these comedians jim and bill both have
boundaries that they can't seem to work
through
i don't know jim i've known you for 25
years i still have no idea what you
think or feel about anything i don't
know how to feel i need help
i just don't know how to be honest
i don't even know you're so walled off
you're even mocking
me saying how [ __ ] walled off you are
i have the same anger as you
i know you do
i said flying a helicopter for the
record is some tom brady [ __ ] and it is
i didn't you know
can i point something out flying you're
like flying in the helicopter like
people that are like use my pronoun
correctly use my helicopter pronoun
correctly oh you're gonna throw oh
you're gonna oh yeah [ __ ]
you're gonna throw me in that barrel i'm
like um
it's you know it's some honest ribbing
and we'll be right back
all right that's it
jim gaffigan i love you brother thank
you thank you
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better nfl preview show
sponsored by as always bet mgm the most
reliable name embedding the most
reliable lines guys uh as you know the
anything better podcast has teamed up a
while back at the beginning of the
season with bet mgm okay and now we have
we have deals for you we have money
makers for you
uh although we haven't hit any monday
night specials lately so i don't want to
get crazy but
um we'll be using the lines
to make all of our picks and we'll have
special offers for our listeners each
week okay if you haven't signed up to
bet mgm yet use promo code bur b-u-r-r
and you'll get 100
for free after placing your first one
dollar bet here's how it works you
download the bed mgm app very simple you
sign up using bonus code bur b-u-r-r
very simple okay place your first one
dollar money line bet on any nfl game
that's four [ __ ] quarters
one dollar okay you're going to receive
100 in free bets immediately after
placing your bet regardless of the
outcome just make sure you use bonus
code bur b-u-r-r when you sign up guys
we are going into week 16
um unfortunately dude these are like
pre-season games because of all the
[ __ ] covet going on dude
and with playoff implications so it's
pretty nuts uh what are they a bunch of
guys are out oh dude players teams have
eight to six six to eight players out
starting quarterbacks i mean it's uh
it's [ __ ] up
um
okay so last week bill once again bill
goes 500 keeping his record four games
over 500 bill is uh two and two last
week at 33 26 and one
uh i am 32 and 28 four games above 500
went three and one last week um and we
are separated now by
a game and a half with three weeks to go
we missed the monday night special uh
again so we have to regroup man we came
close a couple of times we hit it once
we're gonna have to regroup and take
that one a little more hard now with
with all of these guys being [ __ ] out
and all of that [ __ ] plus i gotta be
watching more football if i'm gonna do
well on this but i just don't have the
[ __ ] time
all right well here we go
i had no idea the rams front four was
the way it was man they are impressive
all right let's go you go first
um no it is uh even weak so you go first
all right i'm gonna tell you this paul
verzi actually said to me bill you know
what if you don't take the patriots
worth the first [ __ ] take i'm gonna
take him and you know what i'm gonna say
paul i'm gonna defer it i'm gonna take
the ball in the second half
i [ __ ] hate this game um you know
what i absolutely hate this game paul
because we already beat the bills and we
beat the bills because there was like 50
you listen to me when i'm talking to you
[ __ ] i'm listening
at your goddamn phone i got to get the
games it was 50 not [ __ ] wins we
threw the ball [ __ ] two to three
times it was a complete anomaly of a
game
the bills the light switch was on it's
off and i feel like it's on again i have
no [ __ ] idea what's gonna happen i
love what the patriots did last week
after getting jumped on
matt jones throws two [ __ ] picks and
then he settles down has the poise to
come back scared the [ __ ] out of him
gambled on a play and and gave up a big
run
i'm staying away from it uh i'm gonna
bet the team i should have bet last week
the new york jets
um getting one at home against the
jacksonville jaguars
wow
um well you know what's funny is i'm not
taking the patriots because i looked at
that game after saying that and i'm
afraid of how desperate the bills are so
i'm not taking that game but speaking of
desperation it wasn't what i just told
you
it's definitely not what you just told
me i was going to tell you i'm not so
not taking that you sent me a warning
text yesterday you were taking that game
was it a warning or was it a cool
[ __ ] friend thing to do that's what i
thought it was oh taking your friend's
team is not a cool thing on any how you
slice it well i that's why i said to you
but here's what i'm doing no no no no
let's see that's not you just made
yourself the hero in there paul i don't
think i like that
i mean first of all you already stepped
on my toes a couple of times taking the
patriots
and they're going on a wonderful run
without calling me and you can't just
let you know if you know if you don't
[ __ ] your wife tomorrow i'm gonna [ __ ]
her that's basically what you did
let's take it a little far
um
dude the pittsburgh steelers are playing
for their lives
they're getting slipping into their
playoff lives they're playing for their
lives they're getting
they're getting seven and a half points
against the chiefs this is a [ __ ]
crazy game where it could be a blowout
but i just feel that the fact that they
are in pittsburgh i believe they're in
pittsburgh let me make sure that if
they're on the bottom they're in
pittsburgh yes
um
they are
in
they are in pittsburgh
no they're not they're in kansas city
getting seven and a half [ __ ]
you know what
tyreek hill is out with covet [ __ ] it
i'm taking the pittsburgh steelers
getting seven and a half playing for
their lives ben roethlisberger's this is
his last year and i think because last
year he's going to go out in the
playoffs not in the regular season i'm
taking the steelers with seven and a
half against the chiefs all right i
gotta ask this is is [ __ ] uh
is aaron rodgers playing
yes how about the uh how about baker
mayfield is he playing
um
i don't know that i don't know
all right yeah this is this week is just
stupid i'm gonna take the green bay
packers giving seven and a half at home
against the cleveland browns
no bacon uh for my second pick
no baker nope no baker mayfield they're
only getting seven and a half points
right now says he's out
all right
go ahead
okay
i am going to take wait who do you build
actually competing information so uh six
hours ago they said no 36 minutes ago
they said they anticipate baker to play
saturday against the packers
uh but yeah so
his quarantine expires on friday so
that's subject to change but
as of right now it looks like it's a 51
chance he's gonna play okay
all right everybody's telling me paul
every time you take my
san francisco 49ers they win take it
take it take it but they're playing
they're playing the titans tonight and
i'm scared of the game um i think what
i'm gonna have to do is i think i'm
gonna have to take
why are you afraid of that game
i'm afraid of that game henry is out
i know henry is out but um henry
seems like the 49ers are different on
the road than they are at home
the titans have a win at home the tight
the the titans lost
titans just lost and they need a win to
keep up
i don't like the game i'm not going to
touch it i'm going to take the i'm going
to take the chargers you [ __ ] [ __ ]
god damn it you do that to me every
[ __ ] week i'm gonna take the chargers
over the texans minus 10. that's a gift
that's a [ __ ] win you [ __ ]
god damn it
why did i say the jets first you never
would have taken the [ __ ] jets it was
such a stupid move on my part but i've
taken the jets i think once this year
but no the jets have covert issues
there's all [ __ ] because jet fans are
bitching in new york going let me ask
you a question what in the [ __ ] am i
betting on here emblems
if everybody's out
you're betting on colors and logos bill
ah you bastard that was my [ __ ] that
was my that that's my gift of the week
minus 10.
oh there's a jinx right there
huh there's a [ __ ] texting i'm saying
that out of [ __ ]
kicking myself for not going first i
mean i'm not taking that first um
ah you bastard
i hate all of these games
um
i am going to take
i guess tom brady didn't score any
points last week huh
um
i don't even call them the buccaneers
i don't know i i don't know i believe in
the rams
minus three against the vikings even
though it's in minnesota i don't believe
in those [ __ ] guys
oh [ __ ] if it's any consolation that was
my next pick
my thing i was i was going chargers i
was going rams i was going jets and then
i had one other one
oh you were all hollywooded up you were
going to hollywood new york all the big
markets
mom and pop green bay
and then the mom and pop green bay all
right so you're taking the rams yup
so that's my third one so i got i got to
find one more in here paul that isn't a
[ __ ] covid crazy
paul leaving san francisco high and dry
i hope you don't get a [ __ ] punchline
day coming up those people will be
leaning on you
oh dude there's dude
the three games i'm scared of the bills
the niners and the [ __ ] um
the cults dude the cults are plus one
oh my god dude arizona is flailing
yeah what's going on with them
i was winning money on them all year
i'm taking the tampa bay buccaneers
minus 10 that's a paulie pick i got two
picks minus 10 against the carolina
panthers
i think uh
brady and them are [ __ ] just got beat up
but not beat up but they just lost nine
nothing to the saints always good to see
tom pissed off in a press conference and
take him the next week so i'll take the
bucks minus 10 against the panthers i
like that i'm gonna take the saints plus
one and a half monday night football at
home against the dolphins that's a great
pick
you [ __ ] you know if anybody's
playing out there let me what was that
kamara kid out now that i just took it
i got one more andrew
okay
so i have the who do i have i have the
chargers i have the steelers have an
[ __ ] picks the jets first
i was actually surprised you know you
did because the jaguars stink it's
probably not a bad pick and that's a
great pick but i knew you were going to
go with this the [ __ ] chargers and i
figured you were also going to take the
packers
to try to get into your head a little
bit so i was just like i usually don't
like your pick so i'm like i like two
teams paul likes this week
i hope he doesn't take him then my dumb
ass says the jets paul this is why i
didn't do well in school not go with
math
all right
dude i got one more
give me a second here teddy bridgewater
i hope he's okay he got carted off
he got carted off what are you thinking
about uh bill's
patriots
i don't like it
yeah i have no idea they played each
other it was a [ __ ] stupid game guy
kicks is one of the bills the guy kicks
a [ __ ] 30-yard field goal it's good
and gets blown sideways
it's not a football game
it's a natural disaster oh [ __ ]
[Music]
so you just pulled a knife out of your
leg
dude these three games are really tough
this colts cardinals game is tough dude
yeah you gotta like you know what it is
about them they're on the ropes and i'm
worried like they're gonna do that last
right you know you see that in ufc when
a guy looks like he's going down the guy
runs in and then he [ __ ] gives him a
knee and the guy goes down
um i'm taking a hell of a running game
i'm taking the indianapolis colts man i
want to see listen if carson wentz is
going to do it he's going to do it now
this is his time it's a prime time game
i'm going to see if he's going to keep
running that kid jonathan taylor that
running back i'm going to take the colts
i'm sorry niners fans i just you know
what it's two it's tonight it's too soon
i've been running around all day i can't
take the pressure
i feel like the titans are fading
both teams scare the [ __ ] out of me and
i hate the line it's such a perfect line
on the road for san francisco give me
the colts carson wentz in the running
game there you go
so what's going out there in the nfc
west like the arizona cardinals had it
now they might not even make the
playoffs like if they lose this week
they might
lose the
not even make the playoffs oh you're
scaring me should i change my pick no
i'm taking the cults man
um that's cause you're positive paul you
believe in people you always think when
their backs against the wall they're
gonna be like you and they're gonna step
it up well that's what winners do and i
think that a team that wants to make the
playoffs needs to do it
exactly
all right so
there you guys have it oh man that's
[ __ ]
charge your bet oh wait a minute billy
it's time for the what
oh uh let the monday night special who
we got monday night and we need some
money
i hate when i bet monday night and then
i gotta do monday night special i feel
like it [ __ ] with my
makes me question my bet here i'll roll
with you with the saints though i like
that you want to take the saints on the
money line
saints on the money line
who the [ __ ] is their quarters that
tyrod taylor no dude that no tyrod
taylor that's okay
no
tyron taylor's with david woodley
no that kid what's it could taste some
hill that kid had a crazy game last week
that kid's like a wide receiver running
back quarterback he's like a [ __ ]
point fantasy 49ers i mean the saints
have this gonna be a great game
no that's what i mean that's the he's
the saints no no no no no no i'm saying
who do the uh oh you're talking about uh
tua
tatama malopa i totally [ __ ] out
sounds like a ufc fighter to me um all
right
okay so the monday night special uh
alvin kamara rush is one maybe catches
one wait is kamara playing with kovit is
kamara in
this we need to know because
this is what we need to know
um as of an hour ago he might end up as
a backup
all right now
dude what the what am i betting what the
[ __ ] am i doing here
yeah we could have looked at all i'm too
[ __ ] busy to look at this covered
[ __ ] god damn it okay kamara's back up
oh what do we got who's
we got raymond james
stevenson dude if i go 0-4 this week
it's gonna be devastating i'm taking too
many points dude owen ford does not
[ __ ] count this week
nothing counts this weekend [ __ ]
everybody's got the sniffles
yeah anything this week this week is
called unpredictable this should have
been our bye week
um
let's do
let's do what's his name getting a
touchdown pass tua
he's got the mumps he's not playing
can you imagine dude
you're [ __ ] getting married and
you're going to vegas on your bachelor
party and you want to bet the nfl this
week and you got this [ __ ] coven [ __ ]
you got to deal with oh my god
oh my god
what he's playing
who is tua
two is playing
all right so two throws a touchdown
is that the dolphins guy yeah or do you
want to do two it throws a pick
you know what paul you're gonna have to
do the monday night special because i
[ __ ] bet new orleans saints because
i'm not gonna be i don't want anything
good for the dolphins to happen
all right so let's do this all right
i'll just seven and a half
huh
37 and a half is the overheads
you know what's going over you know what
it's in new orleans let's do
let's do a miami fumble recovered by the
saints
that's been good all year a miami fumble
recovered by the saints we'll take the
saints in the money line and we'll take
the over how about you over just because
i think it's just going to be a wild
game okay so that'll be the defense
defense
recovers fumble recover if they can get
but but bet mgm wants us to be specific
so the saints get a a fumble recovery
um all right so here's everybody so
there's no way dude you called the bills
last week what do you what do you think
you said was gonna happen exactly he
said it was gonna be a bloodbath
i mean they won by like 15 or whatever
right
um
did they
yeah did they they came back you won
that one right you talked all this [ __ ]
going there there you know good team
coming over the road oh yeah yeah yeah
gonna be an absolute bloodbath i mean
yeah they kicked this i mean they it was
like 30 something to 15 right i'm
getting real tired of coming real quick
i'm getting tired of coming close to
four and oh two weeks and i'm getting
tired of it i need it but whatever i'll
take three and one the heel and the bet
decide you're not gonna do it you've
come close too many [ __ ] times
six and two the last few weeks the odds
are against you
paul
with that what that fly in the ointment
you could possibly do it uh but you've
gotten [ __ ]
on a couple i'll tell you with that
[ __ ] game i was watching the other
night seattle or something like that uh
what the [ __ ] game was i watching there
was just some blatant pass interference
they weren't calling [ __ ]
i know i saw that game i did i got
[ __ ] the washington football team i
almost had my giant screwed me too what
can you do listen
here's a monday night special so there's
no confusion
the miami dolphins are going to put it
on the floor it's going to be a recovery
by the saints we're taking the saints
with the money line and we're taking the
over there you go no confusion it's the
money to the top i think it's going to
be a wild one
as bill calls it it's the monday night
special making what for people
making money for you
we only hit 2 out of 16.
that's better than most shows
well there you have it guys that has
been the week 16 preview this is the
christmas edition so we wish you all
happy betting merry christmas we hope
you make money so you can get those
christmas gifts and as you guys know uh
please join up we we really really love
working with uh bet mgm they've been
amazing
um if you haven't seen you know what
they're there every week
they're there everywhere mgm's there
every week they're not questionable no
that mgm executives aren't getting covet
that's right you can depend on those
guys
unlike my dad
[Laughter]
if you haven't signed up yet very easy
very easy to download the bet mgm app to
sign up using bonus code burr b-u-r-r
guys couldn't be more easy here's what's
even better you risk one dollar of your
money on any any money line game for the
nfl one dollar
four quarters you're gonna receive a
hundred dollars in free bets immediately
after placing your bet just make sure
you use bonus code burr when you sign up
bet mgm man the best lines in the game
most reliable name in the betting game
there you go this has been a week 16
preview
um we're coming down to the wire the
last three weeks enjoy football
everybody and we will see you next time
visit bet mgm.com for terms and
conditions 21 years of age or older to
wager arizona colorado d.c iowa
indianapolis louisiana michigan missouri
new jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia wyoming
washington only all promotions are
subject to qualification and eligibility
requirements rewards issued as
non-withdrawable free bets or site
credit free bets expire in seven days
from issuance excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step in arizona
1-800-522-4700 colorado d.c louisiana
nevada wyoming virginia 1-800-270-7117
for confidential help in michigan 1-800
gambler in indianapolis new jersey
pennsylvania and west virginia or 1-800
bets off in iowa call or text the
tennessee red line 800-889-9789
tennessee or call 1-888-777-96
in missouri or 1-800-547-6133
for washington that's 1-800-547-6133
sports betting is void in georgia hawaii
ohio and utah and other states were
prohibited promotional offers not
available in nevada
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
december 23rd 2013
how the hell are you
it's the holiday season
and scootaly boppy ba dabba doop boop
boo go [ __ ] yourself at the mall
um two days before christmas have you
finished your shopping yet
you know what i haven't i've been
traveling so much
um
i actually drove to a mall
the other day but
dude and i looked inside
literally pulled up to this [ __ ]
thing and there was so many
i can't even say [ __ ] just so many
[ __ ] people who were in the same
situation i am that they just had to go
out and go buy [ __ ]
that they they actually had people
directing traffic
you know like there was some sort of
flood they had those same sort of
jackets on
like i can see you from mars kind of
official
please don't run me over
i know where the supplies are jackets to
direct people in to the [ __ ] baby gap
and i
was trying to make the light and i
couldn't make if i you know if i went to
go make the light then i would have
blocked the road because i wasn't
getting in so i just had to wait
and i was sitting there was the first
car
and i just looked at the guys in the
coat i looked at people not moving in
line
and
i just said i'm not [ __ ] going in
there
and i drove away and i felt good
i felt good like the way when you used
to you know when you'd skip school
you'd be the only way to school you
didn't want to go
i don't want to [ __ ] do they [ __ ]
hate this i hate it i don't want to do
it all right i don't need to be taught
beyond sixth grade
all right
and i knew it when i was a kid i knew it
right around sixth seventh grade i'm
like yeah i got it i got it this is this
is
this is all i'm gonna need in life
i'm not gonna design a bridge
i'm not gonna make a rocket ship
you know
i'm not going to manage finance
i'm not going to use my brain
i'm just going to be walking around
reading signs
and figuring out
you know how much a pack of gum and a
[ __ ] donut costs all right i don't
need algebra 2 and trigonometry i don't
need that [ __ ]
so then you just go [ __ ] this i'm not
going to school and you leave and it's
[ __ ] great
it's great initially and then there's
that coming dread of like you know well
now i'm gonna go back tomorrow i'm gonna
have twice as much [ __ ] work than it
did today why did i just do that and
that's what i felt like when i when i
drove away from the mall
you know i felt just like when i used to
drive and when i was driving to school
my piece of [ __ ] car and i would look at
my high school and i would be fighting
my [ __ ] hand
my whole arm as it was trying to turn
into the school i would literally
i guess i would be fighting it to not
just hold it straight and keep going
that's exactly how i felt at that mall
and i drove away i drove away from that
son of a [ __ ]
all right and here i am monday two days
before christmas and what have i learned
if you don't [ __ ] go into that
[ __ ]
goddamn cesspool
you're not gonna have any gifts and i
know what you're thinking oh bill why
don't you show up online why don't you
show up online because i can't see it i
can't touch it it's just a [ __ ]
picture
i'm not doing that and how much [ __ ] on
here is uh is [ __ ] on the internet
my podcast is [ __ ]
all right
does that even make sense i don't know
what it means i'm not [ __ ] going on
virtual shopping
man like your goddamn kids
sound like a [ __ ] old man
so now
like the [ __ ] [ __ ] i am i have to
go to the mall today
december 23rd when i should be sitting
around with a nice sweater on drinking
some spiked eggnog
you know leaning up against the counter
i'm not getting choked up just smoked a
cigar yesterday
leaning up against the counter
all right
yeah i don't know [ __ ] just leaning
there you know people coming over
talking to me
loud music in the background with fire
on they're talking to me and i'm not
listening but i'm smiling and i'm
nodding
you know one of those smiles we don't
show your teeth
you know
you have the same smile as when a kid
draws a smiley face on a stick figure
you just have that smile on your face
you just nod in your head yeah yeah
you're talking and i'm listening and i'm
agreeing i'm agreeing i don't give a
[ __ ] what you're saying because i'm not
[ __ ] listening because i'm happy
right now because i'm drinking eggnog
i'm getting a little glow going
little [ __ ] glow going i don't have
to go to the mall everything's wrapped
it's under the tree go [ __ ] yourself
i don't have any stand-up gigs i ain't
got [ __ ] to do until new year's you keep
talking and i'm going to keep sitting
here with my little pinky stuck out as i
drink out of these fancy little [ __ ]
teacups that has my spiked eggnog in it
that my friends is what i should be
doing but no
that old freckleface
freckleface has to go back down to the
[ __ ] mall today hoping that there's
enough pork
sons of [ __ ] out there with such evil
[ __ ] bosses that they actually have to
go to work on december 23rd they got to
show up at their cubicles and maybe
with a little bit of luck
i can go down there
between their half a [ __ ] day
run in there and buy some [ __ ]
that i then have to take home and rap
um
you know if you're a political prisoner
right now and you're listening to this
you know what you scratch another day
on the wall trying to not lose your mind
i know what you're thinking
you're probably thinking you know well i
would love to have some problems like
that
you know
and you know what i say to you
i say to you uh you know
walk a day in my [ __ ] shoes all right
there
stuck in a prison cell haven't seen
loved ones in 12 years
okay
you know if your presence sells so bad
how the [ __ ] did you get a [ __ ]
device to download this podcast so you
had to listen to it once you explain
that one
political prisoner did they give you a
keyboard to write in some questions here
to make me feel [ __ ] bad
um
i just did that before somebody went
first world problems
you know what i hate more than anything
i hate [ __ ] expressions not
expressions like a stitch in time saves
nine
which actually makes sense
which i can kind of equate to you know
by the present today so you don't have
to [ __ ] uh wait nine hours in line on
monday
i just hate when uh
i don't know
like a boss
shaking my head i just [ __ ] i don't mind
them i just i hate how they're just
continually used
to the point
that people are still expecting a laugh
it's like how many [ __ ] times have
you heard that how many times you've
heard that come out of your own [ __ ]
mouth
right oh my god i am in a [ __ ] mood
today you know why it is it's because i
have to go christmas shopping
and also because i bought a new mixer
and i bought a more compact one that
would be better for travel
and the guy goes do you have all the
wires that you need i'm like yeah i got
all that [ __ ] i'm good thank you very
much and i come here and there's just a
little bit of a different setup and i
pressed every button i plugged the wire
in every place i could [ __ ] plug it
in and i can't figure it out
all right for you tech people out there
i have the mackie 402 v as in victor
ellis and lucy z is in zebra four and i
can't figure out how to [ __ ] use it
so whatever i'm i'm holding this up like
a microphone i'm starting like this to
be honest with you
um
anyways for those of you who uh you know
we're out there shopping doing what you
should be doing
building snow forts and whatnot um i did
a very special podcast this week with
one of my favorite people
not only in this business but also in
the world uh dave kepner david keckner
from the hilarious new sought last night
anchorman 2 the legend of ron burgundy
continues
um
i interviewed him this past uh was it
friday i think
yeah friday
uploaded it just in case you uh
didn't check to see check your twitter
account or whatever the [ __ ] you find
out that there's a new podcast so i
interviewed him we talked about
anchorman and all this other stuff
hanging out getting drunk together and
singing holiday songs and all that we've
had a great time
and uh it was recorded
it was recorded live at the new all
things comedy uh
podcast studios
so with that eventually hopefully i'm
going to occasionally have a guest and
they'll just be bonus podcasts all right
i'm not gonna be reading any [ __ ]
advertisements and all that [ __ ] it's
just gonna be oh well i say that now who
knows
what if i throw up my funny boner and i
can't do my stand up anymore then maybe
i'll have to do it well as of right now
i plan to do it in a pure fashion
i'm not reading any [ __ ] about chocolate
covered fruit i'm not reading any [ __ ]
about [ __ ] how to how to have your
own goddamn lemonade stand in your
bedroom i'm not doing that i'm just
gonna
interview some people um so david
keckner is the first one
and uh jay moore is going to be my 72nd
guest
now in between him
kechner and jay moore i don't know what
i'm going to have
but that's all that that's i'm just
giving you guys the heads up
okay
there we go um so anyways i don't have a
lot to talk about this week for the
simple fact that i'm off the [ __ ]
road
and other than the fact that i have to
do my christmas shopping i am excited
that the the year is over but i also
have to keep uh got to keep the act
tight
got to go to the local clubs
got to do my little song and dance
because i have a big new year's gig
new year's gig
new year's gig get get get yeah yeah
yeah yeah
new year's eve everybody
if your
[ __ ] botoxed ass
is in the los angeles area i am playing
at the mighty will turn theater
a theater that i drove by for years and
i told
my lovely wife
nia i said someday i'm gonna play that
[ __ ] place
i'm gonna sell it out
and afterwards we're gonna get drunk and
i'm gonna kiss you on the forehead now
god damn it
i have booked a gig there but there's a
few tickets left
to make the dream come true and you're
like well bill wait a minute why do i
just want to go and see you
can you sweeten the pot a little bit is
there anything else that you can add it
is a new year's show
is there something else that you can add
to the pot
to make me say no i'm not going to stay
home and jerk off the internet porn with
the silly hat on blowing that [ __ ]
trumpet
okay i'm going to come down to the
wilton theater what else do you have for
me it's a buyer's market everybody's
trying to get me out to go [ __ ]
twinkle toes around their goddamn
[ __ ] tiles
all right
well i'm going to be down there with the
entire crew of knuckleheads that i go to
the rose bowl with
every year they're all doing about 10
minutes in front of me
we have
rose boat rose bowl tailgate legend
the mean joe green the jack lambert the
mike wagner
the [ __ ] uh tailgate mr joe bartnick
all right
with his new comedy cd salute but we
hyped right here on the podcast he's
gonna be there
joe
aka joe aka you need fif you need to
lose 50 pounds before you talk to me
[ __ ] bartnik will be there
we have master chef
and uh and a heater extraordinaire
jason lawhead is going to be there jay
lawhead
fan
of all cleveland sports
you cannot talk to jason lawhead about
sports anytime you complain about your
team he immediately just says i have no
sympathy for you you won a championship
in 1972
because he's never seen he's never seen
any of his professional teams win a
championship therefore
therefore he doesn't want to hear it
from you and last but not least we got
andrew femilis down there
andrew themless who brings other spirits
that will not be mentioned
to the tailgate
he's also the one that has to sift
through all your [ __ ] emails every
week to this podcast and he has
mentioned to me uh he wants to do it a
little more efficiently
all right so here's how we can do it um
if you want to send in an email to this
uh this podcast the low technology
monday morning podcast this is where you
send your emails to all right you send
it to bill that's bravo illness
lupus lupus
uh bill
bill at the mmpodcast.com
all right and the mmp and mm podcast are
all capitalized bill at the
mmpodcast.com all right and he would
please
he's asking you nicely to just say
please make the subject be revel
relevant to your email all right just
don't write like uh hey [ __ ] face or
whatever i mean you can do that but
unless you if
you're not writing about [ __ ] faces then
you know
if you want your [ __ ] red
help us out here please make the subject
be relevant to the email
um he says i read emails that are great
but they have shitty subjects and vice
versa oh so in other words don't give a
great subject to a shitty email email
number two please keep them less than
ten thousand words some people write
great stories but they are too long for
the podcast in other words i suck at
reading out loud
and uh last but not least i know a lot
of people ordered some t-shirts and dvds
we're doing a bang-up job andrew is
getting everything out there
um
unfortunately this is a crazy time of
year occasionally
merchandise has gotten lost
99 of it has not
gets lost or stolen in the mail who
knows what the [ __ ] they're doing out
there
um out of the 2000 plus orders that
we've had we've had like what are we up
to i don't know how many i think we've
had maybe like
ten or eleven that had a problem out of
two thousand
so and know this okay
if for some reason
whatever you order doesn't get there in
time for christmas and anything just let
us know in a nice generally ladylike way
and i swear to god i'll send you some
extra [ __ ] i'll autograph it or whatever
okay
there you go
anyways
so on back to the podcast here um
speaking of reading out loud i only have
uh we only have two reads this week so
you guys don't have to worry about me
annoying the [ __ ] out of you
with my my reading out loud my lack
my lack thereof i've already got loud
scouts
um
so i'm doing new year's eve
and i was actually thinking the other
day i had a buddy of mine who was going
out to go do a new year's give gigger is
coming up there and we were talking
about how funny it is when they give out
the noisemakers before the show starts
and just who is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
who came up with those [ __ ] trumpets
those things that just hit that note
just hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think it was somebody just hated new
years or never got invited to a party
and he's like all right you're going to
go out to a party i'm just going to make
this [ __ ] horn that's going to annoy
the [ __ ] out of everybody
um which reminds me to tell
every comedian out there whatever gig
you do make sure they don't hand out the
[ __ ] noisemakers before you go on
stage because there is no come back to
hey
um all right here we go the advertising
for this week man great everybody
this is the holiday season dooby dooby
doo think the [ __ ] man great what is
the man great you ask they are 100
percent made in america
cast iron grilling grates that are
revolutionizing the way people grill
named one of 2012's best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine man
great man greats are the perfect gift
this holiday season click on the man
great banner at billberg.com for the
1999 holiday special remember
each monday morning podcast order comes
with a heavy duty grilling brush again
that's the man great grill enhancement
system order today at billboard.com and
lastly but not lethally
hulu plus everybody
you've probably tried hulu.com
now with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite shows anytime anywhere hulu
plus lets you watch thousands of hit tv
shows and a selection of acclaimed
movies on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet and it
all streams in hd for the best viewing
experience with hulu plus you can watch
your favorite current tv shows like
saturday night live community and family
guy you can also check out exclusive
content including hulu originals like
the awesomes starring snl's seth meyers
who's got his own talk show coming out
soon
and moonboy starring chris o'dowd from
bridesmaids hulu plus also offers a
great selection of acclaimed films for
only 7.99 a month
you can stream as many tv shows and
movies as you want wherever you want
right now you can try hulu plus for free
for two weeks when you go to hulu plus
dot com slash bill that's a special
offer for my listeners make sure you use
huluplus.com
bill so you get the extended free trial
and that they know that we sent you go
to huluplus.com
go to it right now or click on the hulu
plus banner on the podcast page at
billbird.com
wow those were those were two very nice
reads if i do say so myself
um
all right what are we going to talk
about this week you know i i like i said
i don't have a lot to talk about and
i did watch uh some american football
for the first time since uh
i guess the last three weeks i actually
sat down and watched some i had no idea
that the colts were in it i thought the
colts were like beating every good team
in the league and then [ __ ] in the bed
against bad ones and they were gonna be
about eight and eight evidently they're
gonna make the playoffs playoffs
um i still like the seattle seahawks
despite the fact that they lost to the
arizona
cardinals um
i still think it is theirs to lose
anyways i watched the patriots
ravens game yesterday and i was
embarrassed by that officiating
christ what the [ __ ] did the ravens do
that was like watching an nba game
um
and sad to say a lot of the calls it's
not even the reps fault those are like
the new rules
i think for our first touchdown what
happened was one of the ravens
cornerbacks um had the nerve to look our
receiver in the eye as he escorted him
down the field
and uh thanks to jim irsay
that is that is illegal now
okay after five yards you cannot put
your hands on the receiver and in no way
shape or form after seven yards are you
allowed to look at the receiver
you can't look him in the eye you can't
look him in in his general vicinity
you're supposed to keep in your
peripheral vision without touching him
okay
and if you sense
that he is looking back at the ball you
then also have to look back at the ball
but not in the direction of the
receiver's head you have to turn your
head the same way the receiver turned
his head you know what they should do at
this point they should just put give
like penalty flags to the wide receiver
and just have like any time the receiver
gets touched he can just reach in and
[ __ ] throw the flag because that's
what every [ __ ] receiver does now
when the ball sails over his head as
they're falling to the ground have you
noticed the receivers are are miming
throwing a flag
they throw their [ __ ] hand up
i don't know it's annoying as hell so um
i i was actually surprised i thought we
were going to lose to the ravens
i um
you know but it's just i don't like
winning like that
when like 20 calls all go
in your favor i mean i actually saw
what's his face how about one point it's
just like what
and i agreed with him
i laughed i felt bad for the guy and i'm
rooting against this [ __ ] team
um
i don't know this is just i think it's
all this fallout of i think the
concussions and i also think it's the
fallout of when uh peyton manning and
jim irsay had their [ __ ] crybaby fest
when they lost to the patriots yet again
and they made the tape and they went to
the nfl and the nfl was going that's
legal that's legal
and then they bitched again they bitched
her in the [ __ ] pro bowl they bitched
at the pro bowl they bitched during the
week of the super bowl they [ __ ] right
up to the [ __ ] draft and then jim
irsay who sits on the rules committee
spearheaded all these new
uh
[ __ ] rules of coverage and
i don't know it's not the game that i
grew up with i still love watching it
um
that was [ __ ] great yesterday i had a
couple buddies over got the fire going
uh unfortunately i didn't get to watch
the packers steelers with the snow on
the ground i was watching uh what did i
watch yesterday watch patriots ravens
and then i watch some of the eagles
late night game
um and i guess they're playing real well
i don't know a lot of [ __ ] that's going
on i'm getting caught up in hockey
i watched a couple bruins sabers games
you know 1-1 we lost one
and uh
i don't know i it's funny a lot of i i
saw what sean thornton did you know
against the penguins penguins fans are
[ __ ] hilarious i think they actually
have a lot of guilt
with some of the absolute animals that
they've had
on their team
because they're really trying to compare
going like act like sean what sean
thornton did
and everything that matt cook did like
that's a wash
like penalties offset like one
disgusting horrible piece of [ __ ]
move by thornton
washes out cook's entire three-year
terror run before he turned his game
around which i do give him credit for
now he plays the game a lot you know
cleaner or whatever
um
i can really listen to it from any other
anybody else other than penguins fans i
mean you guys have off samuelson in your
ring of honor i really think you're
making a statement when you do something
like that when you put a guy like that
up there next to [ __ ] mario lemieux
i mean it's just it's unbelievable uh
and i was actually talking to somebody
about some of the most dirtiest players
i've ever seen
since i've watched the game all the way
back to the club the claude lemieux the
dale hunters and all those
uh you know in my top 10 list like two
of them are our pittsburgh penguins
and i think to make that list you have
to have that reptilian sort of brain
where you can end a guy's career
and like in between periods just sit
there eating a sandwich and you're not
nauseous at all
please don't give a [ __ ]
that scary
that scary [ __ ] thing where people on
the ice have their head on a swivel like
where is he where is he
um
and there's a very special few
that have that have uh
that have done
that have just brought that vibe to it
but anyways i'm psyched to get back into
watching hockey and that type of stuff
and uh
there has to be a happy median medium
with this [ __ ] yet another record uh
peyton manning congratulations he just
threw for 51 [ __ ] touchdowns but does
it even i mean and it's he's phenomenal
but with
you can't cover receivers anymore so i
think that they have to have they should
just sense these new rules almost like
the steroid era like you have to have a
new wing as far as uh records go because
if you essentially couldn't cover a
[ __ ] receiver past five yards
all right
dan marino
all day long i didn't want to [ __ ]
hear it that guy would have he'd have 60
touchdowns 70 touchdowns he'd throw for
6 000 [ __ ] yards he played when he
could still mug a receiver and he still
all these records i don't know these are
all dan marino's records it's bugging me
that they made the game easier
maybe it's harder another i don't know
i'm just a grumpy old [ __ ] man so
anyways i don't have [ __ ] to talk about
this week and somehow i've managed to
still talk for 25 minutes because i'm a
goddamn wind bag
and so i was doing my usual [ __ ] i was
going on the internet when i don't have
[ __ ] to talk about
and i was trying to find uh
get caught up on some stories i guess
everybody from the uh greenpeace 30
have been let go
and uh
two of the [ __ ] riot members go free in
russia
russia you know i swear to god if you're
hippies or you're singing in a band they
stick you in prison really old school
new prison amnesty seen by critics as an
attempt to ward off criticism of human
rights record ahead of the winter
olympics
oh yeah i guess they spent a ton of
money on the winter olympics like they
bought a bunch of fake snow
vladimir putting in whatever the [ __ ]
his name is he bought a bunch of fake
snow just in case there isn't snow
in the posh area that they want to have
the olympics so um
you know it is you can put anonymous
people in prison
and uh nobody really pays attention but
uh if they're a bunch of hippies
attached to greenpeace everybody pays
attention and if they're in a band
called [ __ ] riot people give a [ __ ]
so uh one of the [ __ ] two of the [ __ ]
riders
that's the name of the band just got out
of jail uh the third member of the
russian punk band [ __ ] riot what does
she do two and a half years
uh released from custody following an
amnesty law passed by parliament
uh
um
let me at least try to do her last name
tola kona kova tola kono krova
tola kono
no
left prison
left the prison colony in eastern
siberia they put something in a [ __ ]
bat in a punk ban in siberia on monday
hours after another band member
maria normal name
alakina
i don't know how to say it was released
in another region
the amnesty that enabled their release
is seen as the kremlin's attempt to
soothe criticism of russian's human
rights record ahead of the winter
olympics in sochi in february i don't
know if i'm saying any of this right
uh one okay the one of them was 25 the
other 24 were convicted of hooliganism
for performing a crude punk prayer in a
cathedral against putin's ties to the
russian orthodox church the two women
have been do
have been due for at least in march
how much time did they do
i don't [ __ ] know was that even
remotely exciting well if you thought
that was boring here's another one
there's another russian guy
kalish kalish
nikov kalishkanov kalishnik what the
[ __ ] is with the 12 consonants in a row
a l a
s h n
i k o v i'm good with the
kalash oh there it is kalashnikov
assault rifle designer dead at 94.
and you're probably like bill why do i
give a [ __ ] about this guy who is this
guy all the rednecks know him
this guy was the inventor of the ak-47
um the assault rifle designer of the
ak-47 assault rifle that killed more
people than any other firearm has died
um the designer of the assault rifle
that killed more people than any other
he died at 94.
um
he was in his 20s when he created the
ak-47 well there's a go-getter just
after world war ii he died in his home
city of uh well you know something that
i don't feel bad from after what the
[ __ ] germans did coming into their
goddamn country
he's like he's a real patriotic guy he
said well we got to be able to mow down
these crouch next time they come over
the border
and he made the ak-47 so my hat's off to
him
um
and last but not least this is what's
going on in the world according to my
[ __ ] skimming
thousands rally against racism in sweden
i was just there i didn't realize that
they had uh neo-nazis in sweden
oh that's disgusting thousands of swedes
demonstrating against racism and nazism
have gathered in stockholm in a
stockholm suburb
a week after a smaller rally in the same
district was attacked by neo-nazis what
kind of a jerk-off joins a [ __ ]
neo-nazi group
what is it about hitler that you're
looking at going oh yeah
there's the guy that makes sense
i don't know what is it is they have
nothing else going on in their life
other than the fact that they're white
um
you're white you're a white male
heterosexual how much further down the
track do you need to start the race and
you still lose
so then you gotta blame somebody else
who starts nine miles in the other
[ __ ] direction and they catch up with
you
oh you whiny [ __ ]
okay so crowds marched on evidently they
had an anti-racism march
and these neo-nazis attacked it
you know
is is there ever an uglier look on
somebody's face when they're pro-racism
when they're attacking somebody it's the
[ __ ] most hateful look look at that
son of a [ __ ]
so crowds marched on sunday towards a
spot in kartharp
it's the south of the capitol where
music performances and speeches were
held organizers of the event said
sixteen thousand people attended the
rally well thank god for those sixteen
thousand about a hundred uniform police
were deployed at the event
uh police spokesman said that's good one
person for every six sixteen hundred
people
what could go wrong
um you know is that right or 160
oh jesus bill don't be doing math in
your head i've been to many
demonstrations in my life and this is
one of the biggest that's great that's
great said some [ __ ] person that i
can't uh pronounce their name it shows
how we many uh how many we are fighting
for the equal value of all human rights
and that we are many in comparison to
the extremists
i think many people are worried about
the rise of the far right in europe and
want to show that in sweden we are
taking another route how about you're
taking a new route
didn't you let the nazis use your train
systems to go into [ __ ]
norway
ah jesus
i actually it's just always going to be
around
it's just always going to be around and
i guess
how do you think you combat that [ __ ] do
you have to fight it with violence
how else do you do it
these guys i don't understand them
are you not eating every day do you not
have a roof over your head what is the
[ __ ] problem
that's depressing all right why did i
read that that just put me in a bad
[ __ ] mood
is there anything worse than [ __ ]
neo-nazis
the sons of neo-nazis
um anyways let's let's let's read some
[ __ ] here
christmas shopping i talked about my new
mixer i talked about penguins fans i
talked about uh
nfl football i don't know what else to
tell you you know what it is this week
people i just have unbelievable anxiety
they have to go
out and shop
you know what's funny when i actually
went out browsing the other day
i actually saw a bunch of [ __ ] from me
and if that isn't the ultimate
sign
of what a selfish [ __ ] you are
um
i can't find anything for anybody oh i
would like that
i would enjoy that
um all right anchorman 2 bill
broadcaster saw anchorman 2 it was
brilliant the whole cast is great
yeah i just saw it i [ __ ] loved it um
i went with a loghead and nia last night
we all had a great time uh they said the
whole cast is great but there is a level
of trust when it comes to will ferrell
he always makes the right decisions
love listening to you talk to david
kechner you definitely have to have jay
moore on at some time
uh the running joke with jay morris he
gave me [ __ ] for not he i was on his
podcast and i haven't had him back on my
podcast all right and there is a method
to my madness i don't think you should
go on somebody's podcast and then
[ __ ] two weeks later you have to just
talk to him for a goddamn hour about
comedy and every other thing under the
sun you got to let some time go by
you know you got to let it marinate you
got to let it heat up you got to let
some [ __ ] some water go under the bridge
before you have them back plus i never
have guests on this podcast
i just don't but now we have a studio so
i will do it
so david keckner was first
jaymore is 72nd
so i got to have another [ __ ] what is
that 70 guess
um anyways he said you definitely have
to have jaymore on some time but don't
let the whole guest thing get out of
control you're the master of the
monologue go [ __ ] yourself in other
words keep doing what you're doing all
right need an nfl team hey william
i've really gotten into the nfl this
season but still don't have a team i
really follow being irish with no
allegiance to any state i have the
choice of any team in the league so can
either be a glory hunting [ __ ] and go
with the seahawks say even this guy in
ireland knows that the seahawks are the
favor or the broncos are being
long-suffering [ __ ] to go with the
raiders of the jets
any thoughts yourself
um
i would definitely
not be a jets fan
because there is
there's a one sip of glory
in there in their entire victory chest
there uh but the raiders they've won
three super bowls
they do have a great logo although their
fan base has kind of made a left turn
with the dressing up and all that type
of [ __ ] the same way we kind of have
these sweet caroline stuff
i try and block that out i like the
raiders the raid is also if you're going
to listen to him on the radio i think
have one of the best announcers in all
the sports
um
i don't know just pick a team and have a
good [ __ ] time i don't give a [ __ ]
who you pile on with i mean i wouldn't
pick a team that sucks
if i was trying to get into the sport
you know what i would do i would pick a
team that's just underneath the
favorites
um
like i don't know i'm trying to think of
the premier league who the [ __ ] i would
pick i don't know who i would pick
but i definitely wouldn't pick like a
man united
um
i would more go man city i guess i don't
[ __ ] know i'm in over my goddamn head
uh but i would definitely say do not
pick the jets
okay
you don't want to pick the jets all
right the jet i am a 45 year old man the
jets have not won a super bowl since i
was one years old
walking around with my big pasty
hairless head
pissing and [ __ ] myself
okay so that's that's that option
the raiders
have not won a title
since uh
my voice just started cracking as i was
hitting puberty
like do you think they're gonna beat the
redskins that's the last time that they
won
ronald reagan was in his first term as
president
all right i'm just letting you know what
you're signing up for let's go around
the league a little bit the miami
dolphins
the miami dolphins have not won a super
bowl
since uh
i got a cowboy outfit
i got a hat and i got some guns
some cap guns for my birthday and then
the big kids as i was standing there
came walking by took both guns out of my
holster and just smashed him on the
[ __ ] driveway and continued walking
away
walking up the street they just came
walking up the street they saw me
standing there dressed like billy the
kid and they're like that's not billy
the kid
that's not even billy the teen that is
billy the toddler and they walked up to
me they took my guns out of my holster
and they smashed them on the ground
laughed and continued walking
i picked them up
i walked into the house
and i handed it to my mother and she
said who did this and i said
i said big kids
and then she made me a sandwich
all right
[Music]
peanut butter and jelly and she left the
crusts on
because she didn't raise any [ __ ]
finicky [ __ ] when it came to food all
right i made you the sandwich said i
don't eat it
um
you remember that when you were a kid
you were gonna sit there until you
finished that
was that a dying thing is that
considered abuse now and you just sit
there your [ __ ] legs falling asleep
and it was her way to just keep you
stationary where she went around and
cleaned the [ __ ] house
so then what did you end up doing you
ended up taking
most of the food
and you [ __ ] threw it behind the
stereo
that was that giant wooden thing that
they had it on you just threw it back
there
did you finish it yes i did i ate it all
and then that was it but you were too
stupid to wait till she walked away or
went to the store and just grabbed the
sandwich and throw it away you just left
it there until all the ants came and
then she figured it out and then he got
sent to bed anyways possibly
beaten with the fraternity panel that
your dad kept all right
i'm gonna have to go you know what i'm
going to nfl.com i'm going to go buy all
the [ __ ] teams right now i'll give
you a little for the holidays
i'll give you a little childhood story
during the holiday season
scooby dooby doo and silvery bells get
on the [ __ ] sleigh and we'll go to
grandma's senile house um i went to the
nhl.com sorry force of habit
nfl.com
here we go
loading loading loading get those teams
are going
all right the buffalo bills have never
won a championship so there's no story
for you
that's one team
all right
the baltimore ravens have not won a
super bowl
since january
i don't have any childhood stories
because i was an adult
so that's a man's team right there
the cincinnati bengals have never won a
super bowl
no story for you
so far the buffalo bills and the [ __ ]
cincinnati bengals zero titles and you
want to add to that no [ __ ] childhood
story the cleveland browns
you take all three of them you stick
them in a spur-lap sack like a bunch of
kittens you can't raise you throw them
over the bridge in the [ __ ] river
the pittsburgh steelers
have not won a [ __ ] title since uh
what 2009 that's a good team to jump on
they get a head coach and they [ __ ]
stick with them
the houston texan expansion franchise
wait a minute before you throw those
kittens over the bridge we got another
one to stick in the burlap sack
the indianapolis colts
used to be the baltimore colts they have
not won a super bowl
since i had just stopped pissing myself
i just learned how to sit on that little
plastic toilet
you know
urinate or defecate stand up excitedly
scream at my mother and point at it yeah
i don't got [ __ ] [ __ ]
right
the jaguars
never won one
the titans aka the houston oilers never
won one jesus there's a lot of teams
haven't won a super bowl
the denver broncos have not won the
super bowl
since i didn't realize i was going to go
bald
and
or start balding i still have some left
in the late 90s
they have not won a super bowl until
somebody said for the first time hey
have you heard of this guy eminem
um by the way if you guys heard his new
album yet
jesus christ
how [ __ ] inspiring is that if you're
in any sort of entertainment the kansas
city chiefs have not won a super bowl
since 1970
1970 since nixon
was not exposed as a [ __ ] liar
the raiders already did the chargers
have never won one they won a [ __ ]
afl title the dallas cowboys have not
won one
since people were winning z cava richie
[ __ ] pants oh no they wanted one in
like 95
right as grunge was dying and for some
reason people thought that that those
guys who stand saying glycerine was a
good band
the giants had not won one since they
broke my [ __ ] heart for the second
time
am i really gonna go through the whole
league i think i am the philadelphia
eagles have never won a super bowl
throw them in that burlap [ __ ] sack
with the kittens
the redskins have not won a super bowl
since uh
since z cavalry she pants
the chicago bears have not won a super
bowl since 1985.
what was going on then since cindy
lauper was actually relevant the detroit
lions had not even won a [ __ ]
championship
i think black people weren't even
allowed to play in the nfl maybe they
were
since 1955 with bobby lane green bay
packers is a good team to jump onto the
minnesota vikings
is an adult cat that acts like a kitten
loser of four super bowls stick them in
that burlap sack the [ __ ] atlantic
falcons why do you have a team i don't
give a [ __ ] that you change uniforms to
black nobody gives a [ __ ] you getting
the burlap sack
the panthers you're an expansion
franchise you get in but you're on the
top of the sack we'll give you a chance
to crawl out the saints won one in 2010
i think the buccaneers won one in like
2002 the cardinals have never won one
getting that burlap sack shut your face
get in the sack
the rams haven't won one since 99 the
san francisco 49ers great franchise
that's a great team to follow the 49ers
the seattle seahawks despite how loud
they scream on purpose
have never won a [ __ ] super bowl they
can also get into the [ __ ] burlap
sack but they're also at the top of it
because i think that they might fly out
and win one this year so there's your
league
those are your teams
i hope it makes sense all right back to
the [ __ ] questions here
um
new christmas tradition
dear billy stovetop pipe
uh how about instead of mistletoe which
encourage you to
which encourages look at this kind of
guy right this guy writes this
how about instead of mistletoe which
encourage you to another person while
standing under under it
which encourage you to kiss another
person while standing under it
there is a new berry and a shrub
combination that suggests you go [ __ ]
yourself
what berry shrub combo would you suggest
is appropriate thanks and have a jolly
holly jolly go [ __ ] yourself
jesus christ dude i actually like
christmas
i thought you would say have a [ __ ]
combination like berry and shrub
that means that someone uh you know some
female has to drop and blow you
or a fella if you're into that
you know
or if you're a lesbian maybe you just
put the shrub up there you just have a
bush hanging from the ceiling
equal opportunity however you want to do
it but if you get the berries on the
side the shrub
you just sort of cut it like a dick sort
of uh
shape
and then there's your unit
i don't know what to do with that yeah
lesbian you just have like a shrub
why don't you like the mistletoe sir
that is kind of [ __ ] perverted right
some creepy guy hanging out around it
and he keeps telling me to hang up the
mistletoe
it's like why don't you just come over
and give me a kiss i mean i'm glad to do
it no it's a tradition
ah [ __ ] i gotta go out to the mall i see
what i'm doing just go out to the mall
i'm just going to buy [ __ ] i'm just
going to see [ __ ] i'm going to grab it
i'm going to buy it
and then i'm just going to have like
do you like it that's just what i'm
going to do all right then i'm going to
get some [ __ ] eggnog
and i can only drink one glass of it but
they don't sell just a glass you got to
buy the whole quart of it
and i'm going to get some bourbon i'm
going to stick it in there i'm going to
get [ __ ] drunk
that's what i'm going to do
leaning against the mantle with the fire
going
um
[ __ ] i gotta wrap this podcast up cause
i have to go shopping
shopping do you believe that how do you
guys do how do you do the internet thing
where do you go for next year can you
help out other older fellows like myself
that don't understand the internet
unless you're talking about porn or
trying to find out who won the game
can you do that for me
i did order a couple of things off the
internet but i don't [ __ ] know
i'll go to mitchell and ness and buy
myself a jersey like i'm some
make-a-wish kid but other than that i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
all right here we go another creepy
email
yet another creepy email uh interested
in younger girl of legal age okay
dear billy blue balls
in your last podcast and many others you
talked about what you think is an
acceptable age gap between people in a
relationship oh by the way that you know
divide by two and add seven that that
guy was taking credit for i like to do
this you [ __ ] hack
the french came up with that
those stinky smelly sons of [ __ ] came
up with that one
um actually the younger french people
don't smell it's the older ones
that have just not given in to
good lord those smelly menage tois
um is that you or me
i currently have a moral dilemma that
relates to the topic in which
as a 20 year old i'm thinking about
pursuing a relationship with a girl
who's 16. dude
what where in the [ __ ] world is she
legal
she asked me out recently and i'm
toiling with the decision as to whether
or not i should take her up on her offer
uh i'd like to know what your thoughts
are about this before you jump to
conclusion and start hating my guts let
me give you a little back story where i
live the age of consent is 16. so this
is a hundred percent legal
you know what i would do a search to try
to figure out where that is because you
conveniently didn't tell you but if i
did i'd end up on some list because i
would be searching where is 16 legal to
[ __ ] somebody
if you go with the french divide your
age
in half that's ten you add seven
seventeen you're coming in under the
[ __ ] wire
uh i'm a very young looking 20 year old
so what ralph macchio ought to be able
to [ __ ] a 16 year old what the [ __ ]
gonna
oh my what what when did this become to
the the uh to catch a predator podcast
i'm a very young looking 20 year old and
can easily pass off as a high school
student you [ __ ] creep
if you didn't look at my id you'd think
me and this girl are the same age
she's highly intelligent and very mature
what is mature in your world
there aren't just pictures in her book
i know pedophiles like to use this
phrase a lot to justify their actions
but i can have better conversations with
this girl than most girls my age and
older i wait a minute this is a lady
i just turned 20
and for much of the time we are only
three years apart
okay
wait a minute
now i didn't expose me for being a
sexist
individual here
all right so
you're both women
i i need i need uh [ __ ] and he is still
sleeping i need a [ __ ] female's
advice here
you know
because
uh
the way you're set up physically this is
how dumb i am
okay and don't judge me here help me
because of the way you set up physically
for some reason it doesn't seem as bad
you
know that you can't uh
you're not gonna [ __ ] him
you know you're just gonna kiss him and
pet him
and laugh at him
that's just so [ __ ] creepy
um oh wait there's more excuses here
i'm sorry um i just turned 20 and for
much of the time we're only three years
apart she's probably much more
experienced sexually than me as she had
previously been in a serious
relationship for quite some time jesus
christ when did this girl start [ __ ]
and i've never had a relationship that
lasted more than a month or two never in
my entire life including grade school
have i ever had a relationship or gone
on a date with someone younger than me
this is an entirely new territory and i
guess you can see why i'd be
apprehensive you keep painting yourself
as the victim i really like this girl
and she must like me but
i don't know what my next step should be
there's no one i can really talk to
about this without them jumping to
conclusions so any advice you can give
me would be help helpful thanks bill go
[ __ ] yourself p.s please come to
saskatchewan okay there we go
uh sometime during your travels you got
fans up here and we're aching for some
high quality stand up um
all right well what's weird about this
email is where i live 16 is not the age
of consent
all right so this is creeping me out um
now let me make sure you are a female i
didn't read that wrong she's highly
intelligent i know penn foster has his
phrase
but i can only have a better
conversation
where did i think that she was a woman
i'm a very young looking 20 year old and
can easily pass off as a high school
student if you didn't look at my id you
think me and this girl are the same age
where did i think that this was a woman
am i out of my [ __ ] mind
ah jesus christ
now i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] to think look if you're a guy and
you're going to make this [ __ ] move
i i just i i don't i i can't get out of
the fact that it's [ __ ] illegal in my
world and i use the french thing cut in
half plus seven
whatever you are man woman hermaphrodite
just be like look
talk to me in 11 months
all right when you turn 17.
and i guess that's legal up even more
legal and i i don't know i don't [ __ ]
know you know
go make a snowman with them uh her i
don't [ __ ] i don't
i don't want to read these anymore
all right i don't want to be like giving
people exactly you know where there's a
yeah eight-year-old down the street and
i'm a young 14 year old and i was you
know
i don't like doing the stuff people my
age do i still like playing with
matchbox cars [ __ ] creepy
all right cut it out accidentally racist
story accidentally racist racist racist
yeah yeah yeah
um hey
bill
love the podcast and i enjoy your work
well thank you very much person i don't
know if it's a man or a woman all i know
is that they're just going to be talking
about being racist and not trying to
have sex with somebody who's potentially
or not underage
the guy that wrote in last week about
the accidental racist thing was probably
full of [ __ ]
he said i read that same subject and
that accepts exact same story on reddit
over four months ago
no way if it is the exact same guy that
started the reddit thread then cool if
not then [ __ ] him
oh anyways have you ever dealt with
someone stealing your material on stage
thanks um
uh yeah
yes i have i've had uh have had that
happen
not that much maybe like a half dozen
times
and i just walk up to the person i just
say hey that's my stuff and i've seen
you see me do it
and then they never make eye contact go
you're gonna make a big deal of this yes
yes i am and then they stop um
but i think people who aren't in this
business uh
they steal [ __ ] all the time
you know if you look at like
uh i don't know regular people can be
hacky just because there's no that then
there's nobody's judging their work
so there's a freedom to what they do uh
but passing off louis ck did a great bit
about that did anybody ever tell you a
really funny story and then like two
weeks later you're telling the story
like it happened to you and then you get
halfway through the story and you
realize that you're telling the story
back to the guy who told it to you
originally
um
yeah i mean i guess people do [ __ ] like
that
i i don't [ __ ] know
wow that's disappointing
that's like twice
that guy stole from that you know i got
this little theory that i uh
i like to do i remember one time i went
to the comedian he and he said you know
i i have this saying
that i like to say and it's free your
mind and your ass will follow
and it was like either a parliament or
funkadelic
george clinton or something came up and
this guy actually was selling this on
bumper stickers
i have a saying that uh
you know two in the hand is worth you
know one of the hands were two in the
bush
and i put it on this t-shirt and i'd
like to sell it
all right dear mr [ __ ] face dear my
[ __ ] face sorry
the new secretary in my office is a
black woman and bake cookies for the
office i sarcastically said
i hope you slaved over these all night
she stared at me and i saw pure evil in
her eyes the question now is do i eat
one or is it unspoken
that they're now off limits for me
um
i i don't well
yeah you made a joke and they it wasn't
funny
i sarcastically said i hope you slaved
over these all night
oh slaved over these all night he has
like three
um
jesus christ dude
um i i think your question you should
buy a joke book is what you should do
maybe watch some stand-up
and learn how to deliver
the only way you that one could ever be
funny is if you knew that person really
well and that was the relationship you
guys had like you joked around about
[ __ ] like that but to say that in front
of all the people at the office
uh
i don't know what to tell you
but you're but you're a selfish [ __ ] and
you don't give a [ __ ] you don't give a
[ __ ] about people because all you care
about now is should can i eat one of the
cookies
or can i not
you know and you're probably going to be
a terrible father and have awful
unexamined children that's what i get
out of all of that
um
yeah you're one of those people that
kind of likes hurting people
maybe i'm wrong i'm judging you on the
paragraph but like the person that i'm
picturing i don't [ __ ] know um
anyways number three hey bae there billy
goats gruff
oh this is all the accidental racist
[ __ ] here uh that wasn't accidentally
racist that was on purpose racist
um because i think if it was funny it
would have been funny
and i don't you don't give a [ __ ] on any
level that you might have hurt that
person's feelings all you want is to
know is if you can have the cookies yeah
so you're a [ __ ]
um that's that was nothing accidental
about it
um number three a billy goat gruff
my white friend used to go to temple
university in philly years back
as you probably know it's a highly
populated black area now how the [ __ ]
would i know that
i guess i cuz i've done shows in philly
i don't know which areas or what anyways
he was at a house party with this chick
and
most likely a wee bit tipsy they were
heading out to leave when his gal
realized she forgot her black handbag in
the other room uh-oh my friend told her
to sit tight and he'll go get it he
stormed back into the room and yelled
out
hey is there a black person here
uh the room felt silent
as he found himself staring an entire
room
filled with black people when he
realized what he said he quickly
snatched the purse
sitting on the couch and held it up and
he said no no a purse it's a black purse
yeah i don't understand what is uh
how did he offend people
he said everybody figured out what he
meant and they all laughed he slinked
out and told all his white friends
did you get it bill is there a black
person here oh what like [ __ ]
person is there a black person here oh
person ah is there a black person here
ah that's hilarious
i didn't get it
hugs and kisses that's [ __ ] you know
what i love is that you realize i'm too
stupid that if i'm reading out
loud trying not to [ __ ] that i wouldn't
be able to [ __ ] uh now you know what
that seems too [ __ ] convenient is
that an old [ __ ] story did you steal
that one too hey is there a black person
here
ah jesus
um
jesus christ people do you not have
enough funny stories in your life you
got to start making them up
uh number four a group of people from
work including myself this is all
accidentally racist raises a group of
four people
from work including myself were sitting
at the front of the light rail
parentheses above ground version of the
subway in north carolina and drinking
all day at a pub crawl at a pub crawl a
group of black people came up to sit
behind us
and our drunk ditsy blonde co-worker
says
welcome to the front of the bus
i got to tell you something that's
actually [ __ ] funny
i think that that's i don't know i think
that that's funny
she didn't mean oh she didn't mean it in
a bad way you guys were just partying
and she just said welcome to the front
of the bus i gotta tell you that is
[ __ ] hilarious
that's that one is [ __ ] hilarious
oh my god
[Music]
all right one of them was funny
i like it
there we go and what do we got here oh
an hour and one
the podcast is [ __ ] over
um
we got the wrap up here now that the
show is over don't forget to sign up for
your free trial of hulu plus
once again hulu plus lets you binge on
thousands of hit shows anytime anywhere
on your tv pc smartphone or tablet
support the part this podcast and get an
extended free trial on hulu plus when
you go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and click the hulu plus
banner or go to build or go to
huluplus.com bill that's hulu hulu dot
huluplus.com
bill
sorry i was looking at the clock to see
if i had enough time to [ __ ]
tell you this quick story i have a pet
peeve
as i was walking through the mall the
other day
and i was hating my life
um
this other mall that i ended up going to
that was more like uh it wasn't a mall
it was like
this strip of stores on a street so you
weren't stuck there and there was this
christmas tree and
i i have a new pet oh cleo
you got fleas
oh baby i like my dog
what's up buddy
huh what's up i actually got this dog to
like one of my friends
i got a new thing that i do i just take
her for a walk with all my friends
with one of my friends
and after three walks three hours
she starts to accept him and then i have
her give her some water
and then i have little treats
and she starts looking at them like
they're a food source
you do that for another five hikes and
then you gradually taper off with the
food
you know
and it's more just sort of petting the
dog and then i gradually let the person
with my dog in the front yard we hang
there for a couple of hikes right
at the end of a couple of nights like
it's like a 15-day process
you know i'm sorry somebody beat you
then you don't trust anybody cleo
but we're going to turn this this apple
cart around aren't we so now i'm trying
to have mr j lawhead become friends
we'll work on it right
okay
[ __ ] love this dog anyways
so people are sitting there and they're
taking pictures in front of this
christmas tree this is such a dumb thing
to be annoyed with but i hate people who
take pictures with their [ __ ] uh
ipad
you know it just looks stupid like
you're sitting there holding a food tray
up in front of your face i really wish
somebody would just step in and give you
a hook like a [ __ ] left hook right
around your tablet right to your face
and knock your goddamn dentures right
out of your mouth or your partial
something
it's just it's just annoying
that big stupid [ __ ] thing why are
you walking around with that thing
you know you don't have a cell phone
what are you doing with the thing i just
want to [ __ ] break it over my goddamn
knee sorry
hey maybe that's a new segment we can
get away from the [ __ ] you know
semi-pedophile questions
what is it what is something that just
annoys you and you know it's stupid and
it shouldn't [ __ ] annoy you
there's me i'm throwing my hat in the
ring people who take pictures with their
[ __ ] ipad or tablet i don't like it
it bothers me it shouldn't bother me
people are free to do it and i don't
[ __ ] like it all right there you go
hey everybody merry christmas
just hear those sleigh bells ring a ling
ting ting tingling too
merry christmas to a christian a muslim
or a jew
i don't care i don't care if it's
offensive to you it's my holiday i like
saying merry christmas to you
i'll take some rouge and put it on your
[ __ ] cheeks and make it seem like
you're happy too
stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ] and get over
by the christmas tree
stop being a [ __ ] content get over by
the christmas tree i will buy you a gift
sorry um that's the podcast for this
week thank you everybody who came out to
my shows this year this was the greatest
[ __ ] year i've ever had as a goddamn
comedian um got to play all these
wonderful venues and i'm gonna next year
next year i'm gonna do another special
oh boy oh boy
um probably in the april may time of
year i'm gonna tape it record it
[ __ ] put it out there and then i'll
work on my next hour
and i'll do another [ __ ] tour and
i'll go to even more [ __ ] cities
because i don't know what else to do
with myself that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
merry christmas
happy kwanzaa happy hanukkah
and uh
i'll see you out at the malls